So, for example, the simple projectile class defines an onTouch function that
does some crazy things. Now, I'm going to walk through them, so that you can
see, the type of logic that can occur here. First off, we ensure that we have a
physics body, to make sure that the onTouch function isn't being called
erroneously. In addition, we also ensure that the other physics body that's
being handed to us is valid, and it has user data as well. Otherwise it might
be an invalid object or a wall or some other static trigger object. Finally, we
can actually call otherBody.GetUser entity Data to actually get the entity from
the game engine that responds to this physics object. Now, this simple
projectile class will actually spawn an impact visual when it hits another
object, a wall or the face of a robot. This nice little block of code here
defines whether or not we've actually defined an impact collision. And then
it'll go through and actually spawn an InstancedEffect object and allow it to
start doing its flip book animation. Once this is done, it actually calls the
dealDmg function on the game engine. This will actually reduce the health of
the physOwner, or the other object that we're running into, by the amount
specified by this object. This allows the missile to reduce the health of any
other robot that it hits. Once this is done, we set the markForDeath flag equal
to true so that later on, our entity will be cleaned up using our sweeping
process.